foreign
[Music]
noticeably absent from a landmark photo
featuring senior members of the royal
family that reunion that we'd all hoped
for I think is some way off in a new
portrait King Charles III stands with
Camilla Prince William and Kate
Middleton and it's Buckingham palace's
first official snap of the core IV
everything I hear about Charles is that
he sees William very much as his
co-pilot in all of this as his key
support act the pick was taken on
September 18th at a reception for heads
of state leading up to Queen Elizabeth's
funeral Megan and Harry were originally
scheduled to attend the event but their
invitation was short-lived A source told
E.T at the time the couple didn't attend
because the reception was only for
working members of the royal family now
the queen made it very clear that the
door was always left open for Megan and
Harry to return if they wanted to and I
believe that it is actually King
Charles's hope that they might well be
able to come back into the Royal fold in
some sort of a capacity as Royal
Watchers recall Harry and Megan stepped
away from their Royal duties in 2020
giving up their Royal titles in the
process is there any chance that Harry
and Megan might be given their hrh
titles back well of course after makes
it after they made the announcement that
they were standing down as senior
members of the royal family that they
were no longer representing the then
Queen they were stripped of those
honorary titles it wouldn't be
impossible to give back those hrh titles
but it would take an absolute 360 turn
on Megan and Harry's part to give up all
of the commercial work and to come back
as fully fledged members of the firm and
I think there's probably too much water
under the bridge for that to happen yeah
Harry and Megan's exit appeared to
create plenty of divides in the family
but as the brothers mourn their
grandmother we also saw them putting on
a United front and so I think many are
hoping that this this is the start of a
genuine and long-term reconciliation
between the brothers it's absolutely
what the queen wanted it's sad that it's
had to come through her death but all
the signs of a reproachment do seem to
be there the olive branch has been
extended
[Music]